uh good evening everyone
welcome members officers and cabinet
members to this overview and scrutiny
panel meeting this evening uh Five Alarm
procedures are if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices down
the main staircase opposite the lifts in
the foyer office assemble in Hawley
Square on the green officers will assist
you to advise when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber with everyone
present please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
why the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting has been live
stream for members of the public this
meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anyone else intend to film the
meeting
and that's a note and we have no members
of the public so we'll move on
I've not received any
request to speak under 20.1 and no
public speaking so so apologies for
absence I've got councilor packman
councilor Moore substituted by Council
vizeki Council of faruki
substitute by councilor Joanne blight
and councilor cup
substituted by a council of Rights is
there any more apologies
no I can't move on any Declarations of
Interest
that's a note okay moving on to the
minutes of the previous meeting we to
approve the minutes of the previous
overview and security panel meeting on
the 20th of July 2023. a copy is in
attached to the agenda pack can have a
proposal please
uh councilor Austin and the seconder
councilor Davis
and all members agreeing agreed thank
you Jacob I just ask something yes I
know when the lady was first
um the first became leader we talked
about the possibility of
um making our minutes a bit more
informative in terms of where we've got
one member said this or that that's the
thing is that something that you're
seriously considering going forward with
at some point
I think Council Austin that's something
to talk about in another place I I you
know I'm absolutely happy to hear what
you've got to say on that but I think
we'll talk about it we'll talk about it
informally outside of meetings we can
talk about it potentially at the
Constitution review working panel so
they're not a script of the meeting it's
just a general overview of the
the tone of the meeting
okay thank you okay moving on to the
main agenda item this evening item
number four the cabinet member
presentation by the leader and it's an
update on planning enforcement review I
call on the leader to make his
presentation
yes thank you chair I wasn't quite
expecting to be back quite as quickly uh
since my last appearance at scrutiny but
there we go
so planning enforcement update on
planning enforcement
um
we've got a few slides for you as you
can see the planning enforcement team
currently consists of a planning
enforcement officer and a planning
enforcement assistant both of whom
report to the planning applications
manager
the way the council operates is on a
complaints-based system prioritizing the
breaches that cause
significant irreparable damage to listed
buildings harm to specially protected
areas including conservation areas other
visually prominent development and
protected trees breaches to section 106
agreements and significant and
unacceptable harm to living conditions
and the council investigates allegations
of these planning breaches by first of
all establishing if a breach has
occurred
secondly seeking to resolve the matter
without formal action where possible
securing an application for the work or
alteration to comply with planning law
and policy and deciding whether or not
to take action following the conclusion
of the investigation
but if we're going to do so it must be
in the public interest on sound planning
grounds if it's expedient to do so
so there we are there we have some
statistics as you can see there's a vast
difference between the number of
complaints to receive and the number of
enforcement service notices that are
served
um
that could represent the fact that some
of the complaints are not valid and it's
likely that some of the complaints won't
be valid it also would obviously account
be accounted for by the fact that a lot
of issues are resolved informally
um without needing to issue an
enforcement notice
uh and there will be others which we
just would deem that it's not in the
public interest to pursue because we
don't know the resources to do it
um uh we can debate what they might be
and whether they should be pursued but
obviously we can only work within the
resources that we've got so you can see
that the number of enforcement notices
that have been issued in the last three
years 12 13 and 16 and there's a fairly
consistent number of complaints I'm not
sure I have to not sure whether Mr
Poulter knows whether those complaints
are in about individual breaches or
whether for example there might be a
hundred complaints about
a particular breach but it gives you a
good idea of the numbers that are coming
in
my understanding is they're they're
individual complaints rather than
multiple complaints about the same
breach
great okay so if we move on to
prosecutions
and as you can see
um
these are detailed
reports on individual prosecutions I'm
afraid that I'm not an expert on the
individual circumstances of the cases
but they do give you some examples of
things that the council has pursued and
the actions that have come out of them
so there's some significant fines
um 123 Canterbury Road
to the original 40 000 summary
conviction fine
um and some another one at the top there
on Margate Road 8056 plus a victim
surcharge
so
so previously the previous scrutiny
committee
um had an enforcement review which I
understand wasn't completed
um
I think members did resolve that the
following issues should be considered
determine the potential utility of a
planning enforcement portal on the
council's website to provide updates to
members of the public and elected
members on current cases as well as
increasing the availability of
information about the enforcement
process for the public
secondly identify how the council could
come up with a more effective system of
prioritizing planning Enforcement cases
thirdly determine how best to improve
communication between the council and
complainants regarding planning
Enforcement cases being handled by the
council
and finally determine how best the
council could include proactive work in
the planning enforcement protocol
and
so the review was paused in June 2022 as
reported to the panel due to the
publishing of the leveling up and
regeneration bill
which will itself have significant
implications on planning enforcement
including removing the four-year rule
after which time operational development
and change of views to dwelling houses
in breach of planning control is immune
from enforcement action so that means
that in future all enforcement breaches
will be subject to a 10-year rule
creation of enforcement warning notices
which is to be served on breaches of
planning control requiring an
application to be submitted when there's
a reasonable Prospect of permission
being granted
and also the requirement on applicants
to submit commencement notices in
relation to approved development upon
the start of on-site work with a
register kept by the local Authority
while a completion notice would be able
to be served on developments not meeting
the identified Targets in the
commencement notice
so there's an extra bit of work there
for the team
things have moved on internally
since that panel last met so the
council's introduced a section 106
monitoring fee
um in April 2023 and this was
specifically to fund the recruitment of
a new section 106 monitoring and
infrastructure delivery officer the
officer started in July 2023 and that's
created additional enforcement capacity
in requesting securing planning
applications
so that's enabling us to keep track on
what we're expecting to happen and try
to make sure that it does happen
the council has procured a new planning
database system idox Cloud which
includes increased functionality for
planning enforcement with the ability to
publish case information via the
council's website and that's expected to
go live next year
a new monthly development compliance
meeting which is led by a principal
planning officer coordinating action on
new Housing Development between planning
assistance for conditions trees section
106 officer and the Enforcement Officers
to ensure that any breaches of
conditions legal Agreements are
identified at the earliest possible
stage
so that's a more proactive way of
dealing with some of the issues and
finally we're putting provision in the
budget for next year to utilize
additional planning for income to create
an additional Planet planning
enforcement role
so that will if you look at the current
Staffing is two people that will
actually make the Staffing of the
planning enforcement team three people
on top of the resource for obviously to
monitoring the section 106 agreements so
that's a considerable increase I mean I
think that we recognize that
um there is always going to be a
shortfall between what counselors and
the public would like us to do in terms
of planning enforcement and what we're
able to do and that we have fewer
resources in this area than some of
their neighboring authorities but again
as with everything else it's a question
of priorities and whether planning
enforcement is a higher priority than
street cleaning or all the other things
that the council does and that's a
decision that the council has to make in
the round
so that's the presentation thank you
thank you leader okay members do you
have any questions or comments you like
to make ends up uh okay I saw David
Green first
on your first slide
I didn't see an item
for
investigating people that do
work building work
that might require planting permission
and I wondered
whether you know
how much of that happens so yeah so that
will just be that would be a brief
because if someone hasn't got planning
consent then they're in preacher
yes it would be
in your stats
did you include that
I wanted to what extent that happens
I've done it
um so any complaint about Bridge plane
law which includes people doing work
that needs plankers and it doesn't have
and they don't have planning consent
would be included in those overall
numbers
um I think it's fair to say that the
um the amount of detail that's been that
we're recording currently uh about the
classification of the types of
complaints is is quite limited
um so
um well I can understand why you would
want to see that sort of breakdown
um currently it would involve the team
going through all of those cases and
identifying the specific circumstances
of each one to give you that breakdown
but we we do think that the additional
resources in the team will enable us to
give more sensitive reporting in the
future about the category of complaints
that's received so
um is it work that's done without a
planning consent is it something that's
been built but in a way that's different
from what was consented
um you know so there's a whole whole
raft of reasons why people might
complain is it bigger than was consented
those sorts of things
um
so we have to give more sensitive
information about those categories but
we also think we'll be able to give more
um nuanced information about the
outcomes of those complaints so at the
moment obviously we've presented
information about the number of notices
that have been served but you might be
interested to know
um you know how many complaints we
investigated and we found that there
wasn't the breach uh how many complaints
we investigated and we were able to
resolve it with informal action or led
to a new planning application that then
was approved at planning committee for
example and so going forward we want to
be able to report that level of
information for you
so Davis
uh thanks Bob
a couple of questions we're talking
about in expanding the the officer team
um and I hear what everyone's saying
about lack of resources could I just
confirm how many hours a week the
existing officers actually do put in on
this and what they're employed for
so the two we've got two offices that
are planning Enforcement Officers one
senior and one one officer their whole
job is planning enforcement so they're
37 hour a week full-time jobs
um so what's that 74 hours a week of
planning enforcement officer times
currently and we're as well as the
section 106
officer role where um we're putting
forward budget proposals for an
additional enforcement role in that team
so obviously that's 50 increase
it's probably worth mentioning that
one of the issues that we do have to
deal with is
developers that have got section 106
commitments in their planning consent
that you know then we don't know when
they've hit a trigger point or we have
to chase for the contribution to be made
or the specific requirements to be
delivered and that with the number of
consents that are you know granted every
year that's quite a task
um so the new officer is going to be
able to enable us to keep on top of that
as well
now thanks for that Bob because it's
quite important because the perception
is and very often there's a there's an
additional discussion going on about
communication and that so it could be
that officers don't appear to be at work
just because you can't get answers from
them so but that'll be answered by the
other inquiry
um with regard to when an enforcement
notice is served
um does that then become the obligation
of the monitoring officer and legal
department to follow through on or is
there more office of time from
enforcement involved once the notice is
served
there's more office of time
from enforcement involved so obviously
we do have support from the legal
service
um and um you know if a notice is not
complied with we need to take a view
about whether we then want to take
prosecution
um for that um for the fact that latest
have not been complied with and the
legal service will support us through
through that process but it does see the
enforcement officers have to prepare the
evidence and they have to present that
and you know be witnesses to what's
happened and so on so there's quite a
lot of work
after the service of a notice if we're
going to go to prosecution
absolutely so and again I welcome
Recruitment and further you know further
and further resources being put into
enforcement because For the record it's
a massive frustration and there's
certain parishes that are having huge
problems
trying to get any response on
enforcement related matters so in terms
of feedback to them it may not be the
the news we want to hear but it is
important I think that we have an
understanding because it seems to me
that for a especially with the amount of
development going on we are woefully
under resourced at the moment in that
area and it needs you know robust
support I would suggest to follow on
from what councilor green said as well
um whilst the recommendations I thought
were excellent about communication and
better prioritization the fourth Point
very much focused on making it on
enforcing 106 agreements and following
through I personally from my experience
believe that many of the planning
breaches are actually on small
individual projects where people just go
ahead
because there is no disincentive to them
to put in a retrospective planning
application and perhaps we could
mitigate that by a a higher fee that
penalizes the individual because I don't
know
no you wouldn't be allowed to do that
because the whole principle of the
system is that the planning application
which comes in for is treated in the
same way as if it was a new planning
application and it hadn't been built and
members are not allowed to take into
account the facts no no I understand it
and that's right I don't think I can't
imagine that you'd be allowed to charge
more for failing applications on
developments that have already been
built but I've I've disappointing things
here but I understand
what I'd like to propose is that we've
we've ongoing look for some way to
disincentivize retrospective
applications particularly when they're
repeatedly done by the same land owners
and developers who form a habit knowing
that that once they've broken the back
of the thing it's very difficult to undo
so but thank you and I welcome the the
expansion of enforcement
drastically thank you Bob
[Music]
counseling
uh I mean when you've got two offices
and you're roughly getting a complaint a
day each of those complaints
necessitates an officer leaving the
building to go and actually physically
look
at the uh
the complaint that comes in or the
potential breach I can see why we've got
such a low
uh turn around on enforcement and I do I
do think that we need to publicize more
and it's the little ones that seem to be
lost so I'm aware of two in my world one
is a a flint wall that's actually being
rebuilt so we've there's a success there
and then I'm aware of uh a 50 millimeter
gas pipe that's been put up the front of
a grade 2 listed building including
taking out a section of the the stone
door
and for some reason that one's he's been
decided that that no action will be
taken on that one so I think for me I
totally understand that uh when you've
got two offices and the third one
arrives you're never going to have a
great turnaround because it's physically
impossible to do that but I do think uh
I would like to understand given you've
only got two and possibly three there
must be a rating a grading and assessing
of which ones we are going to tackle
because clearly you can't do all of them
so I'd like to better understand and if
there isn't a system uh maybe you just
pick the ones you can get a quick
turnarounds in whether they're in
conservation areas or listed or not and
then I I assume there's uh there's a
situation where a planning breach might
be health and safety related which is
going to top a listed breach uh so I'd
I'd like to better understand what
screening process is used to maximize
the limited resources we've got and also
I think it's really important for
information to go back so I've had to
resend emails to the two stressed out
Enforcement Officers to ask what's going
on uh we we discovered the Flint wall
was being rebuilt ourselves but uh
so I put more pressure on these two
people because the residents are asking
me for an update whereas if that update
can just it's being dealt with and
enforcement that has gone out then I
think that would you know if there's
some way of a system being dealt with so
that once once once the enforcement
officer is action something the email
sent automatically to the complainants
then it would probably help
our limited resources to actually use
their time better
and I think part of the answers to that
counselor is listed in the
um
is enlisted in the slides about which
breaches are prioritized I mean
obviously if if a complaint is made and
verified and it fits into those
categories then I would hope that it's
going to proceed to the next stage and
the next stage you know we're going to
have to look at
um
first of all has the breach occurred and
how easy it is to resolve and how and
whether it's in the public interest to
pursue because obviously there probably
are quite a lot of planning breaches
which are quite minimal
um so and I don't think we can discount
the fact that some complaints are
malicious as well because they'll be
people didn't want to development and
then they'll complain about the
development you know um but I think if
if we were presented with evidence that
we weren't addressing
um complaints that fit into the
categories that we've said that we're
prioritizing then I think that we would
want to look at further
Council of I
thank you
um Mr Council Davis has asked had one
question answered about the lack of
response
um our Parish clock
is always complaining that she puts she
puts a request in and doesn't even get
an acknowledgment
I've also got an issue with
a planning application that was
permitted development for a single story
extension
nobody complained I won't go into the
details of why only one resident was
informed but that single story extension
ended up as a massive great Loft
conversion which is now overlooking it
is sitting in one of the residents got
kitchens basically I asked for the
enforcement to come and have a look at
it and they said that they're not coming
and I think that that doesn't help any
counselors because
when if a councilor raises a concern
like that they should they should come
I know they're busy but this will impact
grossly on a residence living
accommodation and quality of life
I think Council one thing I would say
about that is
um if you're not satisfied with the
response that you get from any part of
the council then you should go up the up
the high hockey and at least get an
explanation for why you're not getting a
response so um if something would like
that if it's an egregious breach and if
it if it fits into the complaints that
we're prioritizing I'm quite happy if
you bring that to me but I'm sure Mr
Poulter is as well
and then we can get you a response
because I agree you should get a
response but you might not like the
response but you should certainly get a
response I agree but it would be nice if
an officer came out and
explained it properly to the resident
yeah yeah well thank you I was going to
say much the same really you know if you
have raised something with an officer
and you haven't had a response then you
know you it's right to escalate that
either Ashley who's here this evening as
the head of Housing and planning on
myself
um or
um Council Everett as the relevant
Cabinet member for planning you know you
can raise those complaints in that way
um now I think we would always want to
try and respond to you as a ward member
about what's going on and I know the
team do try whenever they can to respond
to the complainant as well
um to say what it is that we're doing
following their complaint you know as a
minimum we should be giving some
feedback about you know how we've
assessed that complaint and what we're
doing and if we're not doing anything
why we're not doing anything and I think
you know that should be the minimum that
you should expect in response to those
sorts of inquiries
got lost in
thank you chair
um I'm pleased to see the suggestions on
these slides that we're going to put
more information on the website both in
terms of the successful prosecutions to
to put off other people from trying the
same tricks or whatever but also I think
the more information that we can put on
the website about what is and isn't
permitted in the conservation area or
those kinds of things as Ward members we
get a lot of those kinds of can I change
my window or those kinds of questions uh
if that information we could refer
people to this is there on the website
this is there on the website this is
what happens if you don't do it this is
who to talk to that would hopefully save
a great deal of Officer time and stop
people making genuine mistakes that then
take a great deal of unraveling and I
think it will be very interesting to see
how those numbers broke down because it
feels to me like it would be a great
success if a lot of those were things
that planning officers had been able to
deal with informally and sought out with
with the applicant because most people
aren't trying to pull a fast one on the
council they're trying to make their
home better in some way and maybe they
haven't understood things and we talked
about this last week and it's one of my
particular hobby horses it's about us
using simple straightforward language
rather than technical terms when we're
talking to members of the public and a
lot of our information unfortunately has
to have some technical terminology in it
but we need to make sure that we explain
that and if we've got that on the
website it feels to me like that there
will be a
less of a stress on those few officers
who are trying to run around dealing
with all those matters
thank you
any further questions members
Council Davis
um just one related question actually
and and it's to do with perhaps easing
The Way Forward at the moment the local
plan has been on hold
originally for the
recent election and then ostensibly
because of the dco decision which we now
have
can we how long will it take for the
local Plan update to be resolved because
that will also help in terms of future
planning considerations obviously
I think that's a valiant effort to screw
to squeeze the same which is completely
irrelevant to the to the to this topic
councilor Davis
um but the the answer to the question is
that there is uh that one of the major
obstacles to the local Plan update is
the is the government's review of uh
National planning policy and we can't
really proceed
um we don't even know uh exactly which
methodology we're using to calculate
housing numbers so um the reality is
that we're not going to get very much
further down the road until the
government makes clear its policy and
you know it's not even clear the
government's saying um next year but the
government may not be the government by
the middle of next year so
um it's a difficult situation but I
don't think it's got anything to do with
planning enforcement no no not
enforcement as such but it but if we've
gotten clear
a clear local plan then it'll help
prevent breaches in the future perhaps
with with speculative building that was
the connection but thank you
for your presentation and uh members
please note the presentation
okay thank you okay moving on to item
number five which is the health and
safety policy I now call on Mr Sanam to
introduce the report
thank you chair
um this policy has been refreshed to
take into consideration the the it
requires the chief exec's endorsement
and signature and being refreshed to
take into consideration the revised
senior management structure uh for
changes to corporate health and safety
committee structure and legal compliance
it's been through the CMT process has
been endorsed by CMT and has been
recommended to this group to review
comment on and then recommend onto
cabinet thank you if you've got any
specific questions in relation to the
policy I've brought Stuart along who's
written it so that he can feedback in
relation to any particular queries thank
you
excellent uh our gay members were asked
to make any comments or ask any
questions
Council Austin
[Music]
thank you chair can I just ask
where there are
the safety in how that's done who it's
shared with and how you record the
actions that you take as a result where
where there might need to be for example
a change in practice or whatever thank
you
Palm overall always complains and I'm a
compliance officer who's out and about
for instance does compliance throughout
the district to do with employees and
our vehicles and our contractors
he reports back to me and I do an
official report which is only just
started because we've only got just got
the resource but the first report comes
out for the last three months soon which
shows you what we've been monitoring we
monitor Vehicles contractors
my officer was in the port today
monitoring the
mitigate
repairs and it's quite a broad brush
your monitor Vehicles parking right
across the actual core work we do in the
council and it's been ruled out we
haven't ruled it everywhere yet but it's
a work in progress and there will be
reports available on the compliance we
run it a bit like the football so people
understand it yellow cards red cards for
breaches obviously the severity of those
we have a list of what severe breaches
are for instance if you're caught not
wearing a seat belt within one of the
vehicles that's a red card for instance
the yellow card would be probably a
breaching PPE but they're all set out
and been put through the um
uh the union
employee council and it's a new process
we've only had it about three months
actually live and as I say the reports
are coming out and it is
working
and now our staff and our contractors
are getting used to it if somebody just
turning up and going kind of have a look
at your risk assessment method statement
uh seems to have got about and it is
working very well
I think it's also worth saying that over
and above that we do have a centralized
system where all of the issues regards
to health and safety near misses
accidents are all logged so that is a
central system all managers have access
to that to input and also to check on
where they are with them and that gets
fed back as well we're looking at
improving that process moving forward
which is why we've added in an extra
step in the process at the moment but we
are looking at streamlining the way we
do it moving forward so that there's
more sort of timely information going
through to CMT and such so
cancel the wing
yeah I mean it's good to see that you
cover a whole range of areas but I don't
see any dust monitoring on there so we
have a fair number of workers that work
in close proximity to
our aggregate plant and our cement
Batcher on the pool that does generate
dust and I'm wondering whether we do any
dust assessing on that area to look at
the impact of our workers that are there
I don't know if I jail everybody knows
that we have two um health and safety
branches within the council we have the
HSC side which is environmental
and they do a lot of noise monitoring
and does monitoring various other things
that in the community
and that's from the HSC side and more
the employee side which you talked about
and I do do noise whole body vibration
vibration and dust when required
but usually that's from complaints and
I've not had any complaints from the
employees at the Port dust if I have got
a complaint or any issues raising the
risk assessment then yes I have the
equipment to go and do that but I only
represent the employees and that's what
my main focus is on and the public who
work on who are working on our sites but
from an outside point of view that would
be an environmental enforcement uh
colleagues in HSC which work in
environment and they have a lot of res
they've got those types of equipment
noise and dust monitoring when required
and we work closely together I mean
sometimes I'll get a phone call saying
this is one of your Stuart or iPhone the
other Wednesday it's one of yours so we
do cooperate very closely and make sure
that when nobody's missing the Gap if
there is one and there is sometimes
there's a crossover in some points with
contractors and various other properties
thank you Council right
thank you and thank you for your report
um I have three questions if that's okay
I'll throw them all at you now and you
can pick them off however however you
like
um the first one is really about sort of
teams that are out and about
um do we have a
um a system where people can
confidentially report concerns that they
have with operations
um the second point I have is around
home working and sort of mental health
so there's a lot in here about stress
obviously that's only half the story
um working patterns have changed people
might feel isolated lonely sometimes do
we have a system of kind of mental
health allyship in place or is that
something we're looking at
and finally
um
in the governance and audit committee
one of the issues that we we have as a
high risk is the lack of a health and
safety uh policy or not not a robust
health and safety policy does that does
this being put in place mean that
actually that comes off the list
I can see the nodes so that's good thank
you I can answer so from a reporting
perspective it was only uh probably
within the last year we've made that
compliance role within the organization
permanent so prior to that it was a
fixed term contract trial let's see how
it works there's an opportunity for any
member of staff to speak to that
compliance officer report confidentially
and it will be escalated from there as a
matter of course there have been
instances where people have felt the
need to to report stuff and it will then
be investigated and it either is or
isn't an issue and is addressed
accordingly but they do have the
opportunity to say if there's you know
there's no ill will as a result of
reporting
um with regards to mental health uh HR
obviously with regards to the policies
that they have in place are also picking
up mental health for The Wider
organization so although it may not be
directly referred to within this report
it is being picked up as part of the
separate policies that are associated
with staff matters
um and risk what was the last one
the last one was relating to Governors
so with regards to the
um the internal audit which is what
you're referring to and the risks this
knocks one of the things off the list in
terms of the fact that the policies
reviewed updated and refreshed and
adopted once that's done it will drop
off there are other items within the
audit obviously that we're working on
and that's a much bigger piece of work
but yes this does tick off one of those
items great thank you
so Davis
uh but thanks again for your uh feedback
Stuart and um Matt just one question you
mentioned your colleagues in the HSE
side of the council and so on
um who should we actually approach and
speak to about this because there are
substantial numbers of people that have
got complaints about silica dust and
everything although particularly on the
west side of the town so who should we
actually approach on this
we have a it's Morgan
no so environmental it's an
environmental um uh
email address and you drop them into I
think it's on the website
sorry pennies in charge of these at the
moment it would be environmental.health
planet.gov.uk but it's not always going
to be us it could possibly be the health
and safety executive because we're split
in half and have the same issues that
Stuart has to say
uh thanks for that because because that
pathway is quite important because it's
been a frustration for a long time for a
lot of particularly you know residents
if you look on the health and safety
website it actually tells you who's
responsible for that local Authority
what's local authorities are responsible
HSC is responsible and then what I deal
with yeah so it's all on the website if
you look at that it clearly gives you
there is some gray areas but they seem
to work it out you're more welfare of
the individuals
they will look up yeah I even look after
I do induction for you guys on personal
side I remember it well so there's a bit
of a crossover
and it's purely the fact that we're all
working the same goal really we just
have crossovers yeah absolutely no
criticism and it's fully understandable
and sharing resources like that's vital
I think with modern budgets and things
um it's simply establishing that pathway
because as my colleagues as Ramsgate
councilors will confirm we do get a lot
of people with with issues as well we
will testify if you email me and it's
not me
and I will give you an answer uh but
super thank you very much and again if
we can just get these lines of
communication right I think everyone's
life will be a lot easier so thank you
Council green
uh really pleased that you'll get into
grips with recording and monitoring
but do you intend reporting occasionally
to members
on the results of that
so with regards to the health and safety
audit that's been through governance and
audit one of the recommendations is
increased reporting so inevitably it
will find its way through to members as
part of that process yes
no more questions members I've got one
question for you Mr Bundy some more and
more Council staff are working from home
these days so how do you monitor health
and safety in the workplace with regards
to maybe electrical safety I mean I know
in the report on fibroid Services all
fixed electrical systems and portable
appliances utilized by employers that
will be expected and tested at such how
do you monitor that when people are
working at home maybe
staff have got two screens and PCs and
everything's plugged into extension
leads and stuff like that how do you
monitor that health and safety ones
we have just done a piece of work which
is out there at the moment I think the
little end deadline was last was Friday
where we sent displacement risk
assessments out to everywhere who works
at the council with an email address
through the managers
and we've had a huge response we just
got to go through it all and but on that
display screen risk assessment's been
updated now to include homework and
flexible working hybrid and the
questions are on there because if you
work from home you're responsible for
checking your own electrics making sure
your house is safe to actually
work at home also if you rent you're
supposed to inform your landlord you
actually work from home so there's a lot
of onus on the person who works from
home
to treat it like a workplace and make
sure they've got the right environment
the right kind of furnish at the right
place for gdpr it just does about health
and safety it's about gdpr what you're
working on
I personally work from all my waste but
a curtain across the back of me so just
another look at me but it is for our
gdpr purposes so that you can't see what
I'm working on and when we're on uh
Zoom meetings you've got to have
headphones on because you're talking
about public stuff so we have done that
piece of work which is just coming back
to me and I'll have some statistics on
how that is later on uh this month so
that's how we monitor it the managers
are supposed to have one-to-ones where
their employees on Zoom or in person I
think a lot of the managers prefer it
now to bring them in and have that
conversation but I've also advised that
they have that conversation on the zoom
and we've all got cameras all you got to
do is turn around the camera and find
out what
what their what their workspace is like
and when they do the risk assessments
they're supposed to do with the employee
not give them the form
and fill it in they're supposed to do it
with them and look at the screen so if
I'm doing my uh one of my people I would
turn the camera around and ask her to
show what situation she's working on so
I can make a determination if that's
suitable or not so that's what we've put
in place and we'll see some of the
results of that coming through in in due
course
thank you
okay members uh is there any
recommendations we'd like to make on the
report before it goes to cabinet
and that's a note and I thank you to Mr
Sano Mr Bundy for their presentations
okay item number six uh it's a
three-year extension of the dog public
space protection order
so I call on Miss button to introduce
the report
thank you very much Claire and so for
those of you who have been counselors
before you may well remember that the
public space put in order back three
years ago to extend
um for three years which is all we're
allowed to do under legislation
and we made some alterations at that
point
this time round we um ask that you can
read it have a look at it give me any
feedback and that we send it through to
um cabinets for with any of any updates
for cabinet for recommendation for
approval and
we intend we've not made any changes to
it it's just a basic extension for three
years
um to gather any further information
that we may need to to look at changing
it in three years time we have had
positive feedback and that's throughout
the report Excuse me while I put the
glasses on
um so we've had positive feedback around
the traffic light system which we've
used to describe exclusion zones to
people and we use a season every season
we use a dog code leaflet which we
distribute to people so they're aware of
the signs what they can and can't do and
we have lots of people on board
including the beach inspectors or Bay
inspectors cafes and restaurants
um
to make sure that everybody that's on
the beach is aware of what happens with
the dog control order in those
particular areas because they are our
highest footfall
um or poor full if you want to go down
that ring
um so
we will be aware that we do um Carry Out
engagement education and ultimately
enforcement enforcement isn't the aim of
a pspo the aim of a pspo is to
um be able to engage with people and to
educate them to have better behaviors so
to pick up to put their dogs on the lead
and so we don't have
um unlike bog we don't have a massive
list of the number of uh fixed
pensioners we've served
um
it is a remedy that we can use but we
obviously try to detail with the
Education First so
I'll take any comments if anyone's got
any or any questions
members Council Wing I'm a dog owner my
dog does have to wear a muzzle
so do we monitor incidents because
there's quite a lot of incidents on on
Facebook and there's been quite a few
over the last I would say six months to
a year dog on dog attacks uh
particularly in our Parks Park areas
which I don't think are covered by
areas I mean I personally believe that
dogs in certain places should be on
leads because I think we've got post
lockdown we've got a serious increase in
dogs that are not properly socialized so
have we have we looked at this at the
number of incidents locally do we have
policies for our parks have we taken
into consideration the recent uh Excel
bully dogs which you know blaming the
dog rather than the owner and presently
I believe we have a serious poo issue on
most of our streets so is there any
enforcement and what can we do going
forward together because you know you
can't walk down a single street without
potentially dodging around a pile of poo
I'm afraid to say
no I I totally agree with that at times
then we do struggle because people
um particularly after we had the covered
lockdowns have changed behaviors and I
think we've seen that in everything in
society so with regard to the parks and
the dog on dog attacks our dog warden
has been involved in those with the
police obviously the police of the lead
agency but we do help them out in terms
of seizures and transporting and that
sort of thing we work very closely with
them because they're based in the same
office here
um in terms of the Excel bully dogs we
haven't taken them into this because
this was written before that that
occurred obviously if there is any
changed legislation that will be set
um guidance will be sent out to us and
we can adapt for that Park areas are
covered from this
um and we do the dog will notice we only
have one and he does have a patrol route
we do focus on areas where we know we've
got problems
um so if you have an area where you're
having a repeat issue then please let um
myself know and then we can focus the
officer there we also this year have had
the addition of
um the beach enforcement team which I
believe we're we're looking to keep on
over the winter
and they will be taking up some of that
slack across the winter which means we
can spread across because believe it or
not it's worse in the winter because
it's dark and people don't think they're
going to get seen so
um yeah we do have that extra
Council Davis
uh good evening and uh just a couple of
quick questions actually a couple of
points in the report
dog exclusion areas and um areas that
need to be kept on a lead there's
something just like clarified uh the
keeping of dogs on a lead 24 hours a day
under schedule two includes Peg wall Bay
Upper George Shore
but if we come down to schedule
three and the ramsar and sssi Beach
which is all around total exclusion
Peggle bay mudflat salt marsh and upper
choke
the upper choke Shore is it dogs on a
lead or total exclusion because they're
the same areas mentioned in both okay I
I will have to ask the officers that I
don't know sorry there's a Chuck an
awkward question at him
I will have to ask them and give you I'm
sorry but it I think it could do with
some clarity
um there is a
[Music]
um there is one other point actually and
it refers to the
um
about the relationship and
responsibility for um and I can't find
it now in the agenda but um perhaps if I
write to you there's one that it just
needs that again Clarity because it
talks about people being
um responsible for a dog in their
position or a human so it's it's just a
typo I'm sure yeah absolutely I will
look forward to that and I'll make the
changes for the reports
just a little boy thank you
any more questions members
no okay so members asked to make
recommendations to cabinets I presume
there's none and it leads me to thank
Miss button for the presentation
okay moving on to item seven
which is the review of the over overview
and scrutiny work panel program panel
work program for 2023-24
any questions or comments members like
to make to answer Davis
again I'm going to get accused of
bringing in new topics but there's an
important issue and it's rising and it
affects the entire community and this is
the issue of the ceiling down on Minster
marshes
um it's a huge environmental matter that
is going to be and it's going to affect
every single person on this island
um
there was supposedly a briefing by
National Grid which I don't know if
anybody else managed to meet anybody
from National Grid this afternoon I
logged on at four o'clock and was the
only person in the room they didn't even
attend so could I suggest as a matter of
urgency because this is causing huge
concern in the community can I suggest
that we get National Grid in and can
have a Frank discussion with them about
their intentions and what the and how
this affects this community but I'm
sorry to Ambush the work program but I
think it needs to be dealt with as a
matter of priority
thank you okay I'll discuss it with uh
Nick and Charles whether that can be a
member's brief in order to scrutiny or
some fit it in somewhere in that
um can I
asked
yeah sure we'll look at where we can fit
that in I'm not you know I I have seen
the consultation document something not
really I've taken much Notice off to me
okay counselors delivery uh I want to
ask councilor britchett to come in at
this point because I know he's uh been
leading a scrutiny review on our behalf
hi uh thank you councilor please
um so yes we've had the tourism working
group
um consisting of myself councilor green
councilor Austin uh councilor packman
and councilor cup uh although I think
councilor Cup's been unable to attend so
far we've had two meetings so far uh
primarily looking at the
sort of the more the downside of Tourism
and how we can sort of mitigate those
those issues uh particularly there's
sort of noise and social behavior
toilets transport parking street
cleaning uh whole obviously the issues
second homes and airbnbs
um so far presentation uh Louise Askew
uh reports from Mike cumber and Bob
Porter
um
and yeah so we've been looking at those
issues and also sort of
going to be looking at sort of how other
councils are dealing with uh those those
sort of issues
uh thanks just give us some idea on a
time frame for
the presentation of the document
um Brian tending to have something sort
of towards the end of the year
um
sort of a morph a draft we can
definitely be presenting by January
thank you excellent good because then we
can look to get the next one which is a
flight up into the band of vehicles
Council
thank you thanks and thanks councilor
breacher
um I have uh I've got a slight concern
about this one
um not not in the work that it's doing
but just in the tone of it because it
was I mean it was covered on on the news
recently and it was all about the
negative impacts on tourism
um it's it's Margate it's broadstairs
it's Ramsgate we thrive on tourism I
would like to see some acknowledgment or
work to uh
to acknowledge the the the the the
positives it would be good to be able to
say look everyone's welcome just please
behave yourselves or whatever it's going
to be you know so I just I'm just
concerned that we go in in this when
we're reporting it to local media when
we're reporting to Residents what we're
doing in that it is look we want you to
come we want you to visit we we want
your money essentially but please leave
leave us as you find us
I don't think the news report has
anything to do with
scrutiny I think there's a color
councilors that we're not went off on
their own yeah
uh Council can I come back on that
please because I was the person who
suggested it and the proposal was that
we look specifically at how we counter
the negative impacts of Tourism so it
wasn't a generic tourism evaluation it
was looking at what do other councils do
about the impact of airbnbs on rents
have any other councils found a better
way than we have of dealing with second
homes have any other councils imposed to
tourist tax what do they do about
parking etc etc and how does it Link in
with the other work that we're doing so
it does have a focus on the negative but
not in the sense of oh dear this is
terrible but in the sense of okay this
you know this aspect of Tourism is
causing us a bit of a problem do we know
any other councils that are dealing with
that better are the things we can learn
are the proposals that we can put
forward are there is there Intelligence
coming through from officer teams about
how we might tackle X and Y more effect
relatively than we are now and most
particularly other things we might need
to build into the budget to be able to
do that better next year so that that
was that was the thinking behind it
I suppose I can see both sides of the
store the the story but it would be nice
if the document had a forward that just
briefly mentioned the benefits of
Tourism how many visitors the amount of
money the amount of money that you know
something brief because you never know
who in the media is going to pick up
something and pick up on the negatives
and that that's the last thing we want
is for is for people to be turned away
because
on a bank holiday Mr gate beaches are
covered in rubbish which they are and
it's something we do need to try and
find a way to resolve but I would
imagine the vast majority of visitors to
our towns and our Villages are very
satisfied with their visits because they
do keep returning
just to be clear I'm not saying the the
issues don't exist I fully agree with it
and I fully agree that we need to look
at the impact of all the things you
talked about so it is it's it's
genuinely exactly what I just said
uh
okay it's okay
thank you chair yeah I just wondered if
um there was any update on the requests
for officer reports
um there was four subjects review of
section 106 management broken waste bins
review an update on externally funded
regeneration projects and a review of
governance and performance of on-street
parking income
yeah thanks um I was going to bring up
to I mean obviously we've been told as
an extraordinary meeting in October but
our next standard meeting is on the 21st
of November and I was going to ask if
anybody wanted to recommend a Cabinet
member we'd like to invite to discuss
one of those topics so
discuss amongst yourselves who you would
like to invite and then uh and we can
discuss it on one of those topics here
I noticed um mic is here this evening
maybe we could invite Mike back to uh
talk about a couple of the subjects
that's great but he's not a Cabinet
member
so if he did with the appropriate
Cabinet member
well and if you tell me which subject it
is that
okay
not very sexy but I'm straight on the
broken waistband because you go to the
Margate Depot and there's hundreds of
them and all those waste bins are spare
parts that you can buy you know and we
should be I've even offered to go down
there and ever go myself that we should
be attempting to take those bins pull
them to bits and creating new bins for
people who've had their tops
you can you can you can actually buy the
bits online and it's much cheaper than
going to and it's quicker than going to
TDC and getting a new bin you can
actually get the the red bins cheaper as
well the red bags cheaper but you know
they're all sat there at the Margate
Depot just piled high and that it's it's
a resource we could use to save our
residents money and actually save
ourselves money so although it's not
sexy I want the bin one okay so we'll
invite sexy Steve Oldman to talk about
something it's unsexy
uh yeah so that's it a waistband review
on the 21st November from Council
development if you all agreed with that
okay fine
um something I was asked about today
um council is not here this evening to
ask himself was
um he asked about a presentation about
manston which we decided was going to be
after the decision
so
yeah and we are at that time so I think
it would invite to invite someone from
manston to
come along and discuss their
arrangements and how they're going to
get started I think it's only fair
the leader the leader invites him or the
lead or the leader's not from manston is
he
hold on I'll just Dave David Queen
TDC has statutory Duty with a manston
it's a planning issue
there's absolutely no point in the
coming here until they've got a business
plan they can present to TDC
absolutely no point at all
and in fact because it's a planning
issue which which will which will
tdcs
I don't think we should be talking to
them
[Music]
Council Davis I believe you've all got
something to say okay I think I think
the DCA was resolved the planning issue
so it's not a planning issue
at all I think you'll find that should
RSP uh like to come and talk to scrutiny
or anything an invitation to Mr private
would probably be welcomed
um however
I think Cancer's Green's got it very
very wrongly thank you
answer Davis
uh firstly I'd like to remind the
committee we did agree to do this
previously but more to the point
um if it's if we are a statutory
consultee to the process then
I would suggest that with the principles
of scrutiny as we've set out to us in
our training it's vitally important that
we apply some pre-screw to me and have
discussions about their plans for the
future communication is surely the way
ahead not communicating means they don't
get a chance to explain their plans we
don't get a chance to get the up-to-date
situation and there's a lot of questions
about manston and you know it it will be
according to the plan uh carbon neutral
let's have a chat let's let's hear those
plans laid out and uh I'm glad I'm
entertaining the gallery but it's a
matter of fact and if the data is set
out in front of us then we can
scrutinize it rather than just uh listen
to propaganda from both sides
councilor White
uh chair I believe that my understanding
is that the government's decision on the
project overrides the council
okay councilor fight
as understanding nothing's come to
planning yet has it so
um well
I have I I've got I've got the mic at
the moment right so I just I just think
if once a once a plan is is put together
and it's ready to go then we absolutely
have to scrutinize it but right now
getting someone in earlier like early
we're just going to listen to whatever
story they're deciding to tell this
month
um either way I mean I think it needs to
go to a a committee decision whether we
invite
River oaking councilor Wing uh whether
we like it or not we are the statutory
planning authority over that piece of
land and I sit on planning
and I would feel compromised we have
never ever ever I've never sat in this
this body here and sat and listened to a
developer talking about what they're
going to do and I think as an authority
we should be very wary of doing that and
as airport supporters you should be very
wary of doing that you know we need to
be absolutely certain whether we support
the airport or not that we follow the
letter of the law and I cannot remember
a time when we have allowed a developer
because that's what rspr developers they
happen to be developing an airport not a
housing estate we have never ever ever
allowed developers to come and talk to
uh a cabinet a a committee that's the
queen
if you read the dco
decision document
there are 24 separate
conditions
that RSP have to meet
monitored by Planet District Council
before they are allowed to put a spade
in the ground
there are other things as well that they
have to do
but we but counseloring is right we
would be in severe danger of
compromising the council
if we if we go outside of the planning
regime
okay so the only reason I brought it up
this evening was because when it was
asked about previously I think about the
first meeting I think it was yourself
that said they shouldn't be allowed to
make that presentation until after the
dco was made which is why the person has
come back to me today and said that
dco's been
so you know because you yourself said
you thought that that they shouldn't be
allowed to make the presentation until
the dco has been agreed which so that's
why I've been asked today to ask if they
can come at the next such uh screening
meeting Council Davis
I think we need to go back to the what
is our legal Duty and our statutory Duty
as an overview and scrutiny panel and
basically anything that affects the
people of this community or the
community it comes under our remit there
is absolutely no conflict in inviting an
organization to come in that has got the
claimed half a billion pounds and I'll
say claimed because you know none of us
have seen that piece of paper so all due
respect to both sides so let's hear the
plans the plans have evolved this is not
and some of us have been monitoring this
situation and by for the record I
support the reopening Advanced and
Aviation I have not said that I
unequivocally support any individual
operator up there or any individual
application I uh I may be predisposed to
support Aviation but I'm certainly not
predetermined and would not be
predetermined which is why I think it's
absolutely important and our duty as a
scrutiny panel to invite them in and to
allow them an opportunity to set out
how they how they intend to proceed our
statutory Duty within the planning
matters is to ensure that the authority
given to them under the dco is delivered
legally and lawfully
therefore it falls under scrutiny
okay just go to council bright first and
then to you Catherine
like I say I I agree that we need to
scrutinize it once there is something on
the table that's actually going to
happen but right now
as you say we we have to think about the
statutory obligations
counselor Wing is on this on this
Council councilor bright is sitting here
tonight on this Council
um I believe councilor rajeski councilor
Moore all sit on planning how can you
have a developer presenting plans for
their development to people that are on
planning that's it's far too cozy for me
and I think it risks predetermination I
think this needs to go to a vote because
we're not we're just going to talk
around this do we want to invite RSP in
for a presentation in the next couple of
meetings yes or no that's what I think
okay so I've been advised but it's best
not to invite them at the moment because
as I'm outstanding planning details
so we weren't invited them to discuss
burning matches and just being told by
our legal advisor is telling me
scrutinized something which has been
presented to us nothing has been
presented to thanet District Council
it's been presented to the government so
we cannot have somebody in and
scrutinize something which has not been
presented to us
I'm sorry to interrupt but I think it's
important because there have been
opportunities previously and in previous
administrations for River open RSP to
present to this Council and they've been
denied that opportunity consequently
um
and it's always been pushed back or we
wait until and wait until
we are doing today
hold you there can I just bring in
I just want to clarify in terms of what
councilor brighter said he's absolutely
right there's certain members who are
sitting on the planning committing to
bring anything back here make a
predetermination so we can't have that
not until the planning is actually all
done and dusted and then at that point
you've got everything out of the way
then you can but at this point it it's
not possible
I I we can have a vote but it doesn't
seem like a vote
yeah no I don't think a vote is
necessary but we will
okay
okay so um is there any any suggestions
for any other presentations uh Council
Austin
so uh picking up on what uh councilor
Curry said before about monitoring on
our
um on our regeneration projects just
that just that little timeline just that
little Gantt chart saying where we are
with all the projects so not asking an
officer to come and talk about
what's happening and I know we've got an
extraordinary meeting where we will have
an officer coming to do that but just
that can we establish at that at every
meeting we get something that says where
we are with the different projects
because there's a lot floating around in
the local media about this and this and
this being delayed and we get asked
about it as scrutiny we need to be
monitoring that closely so just Louise
was talking at last week's meeting about
the new arrangements with the government
and about the red Amber green system
just
um as as Stewart was talking about they
do with health and safety that will be
brilliant and if we can have that coming
to us every meeting then we can keep an
eye on it we really need to be doing
that that really is part of our
responsibility
okay as as part of the pilot scheme
that's just been agreed I think there's
some reporting mechanism that's going to
be involved in that I think council
department might have something to say
because I think he asked the question uh
the other day at cabinets it was and I'm
and I I'd like to support that and I'd
second it if Council Austin wants to
propose it because I think we last week
we discussed it it was discussed again
in cabinet and I and I felt that we we
there's probably a lot of agreement on
that so I actually think we need to push
quite hard on this
I think also the leader did actually say
that overview and scrutiny is not the
scrutiny of all the leveling up project
is cabinet other scrutiny of the living
up projects it's their their decision
makers not scrutiny but I mean yeah I
mean we are called overview I would say
we are we are the scrutiny panel we have
a monitoring role I believe it's vital
that we monitor this on a regular basis
that it's just part of our standard of
gender it doesn't have to take a lot of
opposite time it's part of the reporting
they're doing anyway it doesn't need an
officer to come and tell us what's going
on unless they specifically want to well
this is an item on the agenda it's just
something that we need to note at every
meeting where we're at with this and yes
obviously at the end of the day the
decisions are cabinets but we are the
scrutiny panel we are a council that has
had huge problems with its monitoring
its governance its transparency we
really need to be doing this and to be
seen to be doing this
okay Council so I'll definitely put that
uh that forward
okay so
um moving on to item eight on the agenda
which is
I think I just do as a chairs chairs
request I think and then yeah okay okay
moving on to item eight the forward plan
and exempt cabinet decision list I'm
sure you've all had a chance to have a
look if there's anybody wish to make a
comment on that
nope okay so that's concludes the
business for tonight's meeting I declare
this meeting closed and I thank you all
for attending thank you